[Musique]
jouer c'est fini pour de bon encore
aujourd'hui je n'osais pas été possible
d'aimer autant aussi longtemps tu dois
mener qu'à - luis un mois mois
[Musique]
c'est un de ses amis qu'avec leurs
locaux karl vernay tourner dans un film
quel genre de film et détonnant
fait pas que des types sont parents
et en deux minutes je veux tous à poil
et regarda vaut plus raide que giscard
on se soulagent avec la main à raison
entre copains
[Musique]
sur le plateau il était du genre
insatiable les huits luminy un merci de
ses partenaires comme possédés
savez quand on s'oublie avec l'autre
qu'on sait plus où on en est
sa mère est une forme d'amour en quelque
sorte puisse enfin
brasse
c'était le dernier plan du tueur mots
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]